nous accueillons pour la deuxième
audition de ce jour Monsieur
Marc-Olivier Fogiel qui est directeur
général pardon de BFM TV Monsieur le
Directeur général je vous remercie
d'avoir répondu à notre convocation
d'être présent aujourd'hui nos accords
du temps pour répondre à nos questions
question qui je tiens à dire et je l'ai
dit hier je le redis aujourd'hui ne vise
absolument pas entretenir une quelconque
polémique ou à créer une affaire si elle
n'existe pas mais à comprendre tout
simplement un phénomène qui est apparu
dans les médias et qui intéresse nos
qu'on ne concitoyens parallèlement à nos
travaux qui portent donc sur les
ingérences ou les tentatives d'ingérence
étrangères sur les personnes politiques
les agents publics les intérêts
économiques mais aussi sur les relais
d'opinion évidemment votre chaîne joue
un rôle considérable dans le débat
d'idée et la bonne information de nos
concitoyens BFM TV c'est donc retrouver
récemment au cœur d'une polémique ou
d'une affaire qui touche notre notre
commissions d'enquête puisqu'il
s'agirait selon les enquêtes qui ont été
diffusées par un certain nombre de vos
confrères et concerts d'une d'un soupçon
d'ingérence étrangère et de manipulation
de l'information dans les journaux de la
nuit de votre chaîne
dès que ces soupçons ont été rendus
publics votre chaîne a ouvert une
enquête interne puis à procédé certains
nombres de décisions disciplinaires
contre le journaliste
monsieur bark mbarquy que nous avons
auditionné hier
de manière publique et a finalement
licenciement je précise aussi que la
commission d'enquête parlementaire n'est
pas une substitution des autres organes
judiciaires nous ne sommes pas la
justice nous ne sommes pas le tribunal
des prud'hommes donc nous ingérons pas
c'est ce qu'elle veut dire dans ce qui
ne relève pas de nos compétences nous
nous limiterons à faire notre travail
uniquement notre travail de
parlementaire à savoir éclairer
l'opinion publique sur
de phénomènes d'ingérence essayer de le
comprendre et suite au fait suite à
cette compréhension suggérer des
modifications législatives ou
réglementaires qui pourraient s'avérer
pertinentes vous avez d'ailleurs pu
constater hier dans nos travaux si vous
avez eu le temps de les suivre que nous
n'avons à aucun moment voulu alimenter
aucune forme de polémique ou de
manipulation à ce titre par exemple en
tant que président de la commission j'ai
refusé la prise d'image ou de photos de
Monsieur Mbarki qui aurait qui ne
semblait pas ne convenir à mon avis au
niveau et à la tenue de nos travaux
cette audition en revanche et public
elle n'est pas soumise à huis clos donc
elle est diffusée en direct la vidéo
sera disponible à la demande elle est
aussi ouverte à la presse et à tous ceux
qui s'intéressent à nos travaux monsieur
Fogiel je vous laisserai d'abord la
parole pour une quinzaine de minutes
d'intervention liminaire sur ce que vous
inspire cette affaire les travaux de
cette commission les éléments vous
souhaitez porter à notre connaissance et
ensuite nous répondrons vous répondra à
nos questions les questions de votre
serviteur de madame la rapporteur et des
commissaires présents qui souhaiteraient
intervenir je vous rappelle monsieur
Fogiel qu'au titre de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires les personnes
auditionnées par une commission
d'enquête doivent prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité aussi je vous demande monsieur
Vogel de lever la main droite et de dire
je le jure je le jure je vous remercie
et vous avez la parole pour votre propos
liminaire merci monsieur le Président
merci Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés les commissaires
je vais donc revenir comme vous l'avez
souhaité sur les soupçons de
manipulation de journalistes au profit
d'intérêt étrangers notamment ce qui
concerne donc cette affaire entre
guillemets dites embarquis ou BFM TV
au risque de vous décevoir je dois
d'abord vous indiquer que je ne vais pas
vous apporter d'éléments d'information
concernant des accusations d'ingérence
étrangères dans ce dossier pour la
simple raison que je n'en dispose pas
les raisons pour laquelle nous avons
écarté de l'antenne et de l'entreprise
Rachid Barki ce n'est pas pour des
raisons d'ingérence étrangères dans le
cadre donc de ces journaux de la nuit
parce qu'on nous n'avons pas les moyens
de l'apprécier nous sommes pas la
justice c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons déposé plainte nous avons une
attente importante évidemment de autour
de la plante que nous avons déposée mais
si nous l'avons écarté de l'antenne
c'est parce que et ça s'est établi il a
gravement manqué au processus de
validation mis en place au sein de BFMTV
que je vais pouvoir vous décrire tout à
l'heure et donc c'est pour ces raisons
là et ces raisons seules qu'il a été
écarté concernant l'ingérence
potentielle étrangère nous n'en n'avons
pas la preuve et la justice dira ce
qu'elle a à dire comme vous
vu les enquêtes qui ont entouré c'est
cette affaire mais en tout cas en tant
qu'entreprise privée nous avons pas les
moyens que la justice a et donc ce n'est
pas pour cette raison là que Rachida a
été écarté de l'antenne pour commencer
si vous voulez bien je vais vous
raconter la chronologie des faits dans
cette affaire et le traitement qui a été
le nôtre et la raison qui a conduit à
cette
sévérité immédiate et et exemplaire donc
le 7 janvier 2023 Frédéric mettaiso
journaliste aratophonce que vous avez
auditionné m'a appelé il m'a indiqué
donc depuis Israël mené une enquête sur
une société locale
proposant entre autres un service
permettant de faire passer des
informations dans les médias
lui m'expliquant que tout ça était dans
un cadre d'ingérence
d'intérêt étrangers et que cette société
qu'il avait infiltré à ce moment-là il
me demandait la plus grande
confidentialité
proposer notamment de de passer des
informations sur BFM TV vous imaginez
notre stupéfaction la mienne d'abord
j'ai demandé de m'en dire un peu plus
évidemment c'était compliqué pour lui
parce qu'il était en pleine enquête mais
c'était suffisamment grave pour qu'il
m'envoie un sérum de choses et il
voulait savoir dans quelle mesure
la chaîne était au courant qu'elle était
la chaîne de complicité éventuelle enfin
il enquêtait simplement et dans le cadre
dans l'enquête qu'il a publié bien après
me donnant peu d'éléments d'informations
sur son enquête puisque il était dans le
cadre de la confidentialité dans Il
était il était infiltré et en revanche
il avait besoin d'un syndrome
d'information pour pouvoir l'aider
puisque je ne voyais pas du tout à quoi
il faisait allusion je lui ai demandé de
me demander de me donner des éléments
des éléments d'information et il m'a
communiqué trois vidéos extraits de
vidéos qui selon lui était
problématiques et pour certaines d'entre
elles de ces trois vidéos qu'il avait vu
dans le cadre de son enquête puisque la
société en question qu'il infiltrait lui
avait montré ses vidéos comme des
preuves qu'il pouvait faire passer des
informations sur une chaîne
d'information continue en France la
première et il voulait savoir de quoi il
est retournait ils m'ont envoyé ces
trois vidéos en les voyant force de
constater que elle n'avait pas leur
place à l'antenne certaines étaient
d'ailleurs incompréhensible pour le
commun des mortels en tout cas pour moi
qui est la prétention de connaître
l'information
elle et en tout cas elle n'avait rien à
voir avec notre ligne éditoriale j'en ai
pour preuve que sur les
24 heures 20h30 pardon d'info en continu
sur la chaîne ces informations
n'apparaissent que dans le cadre du
journal de la nuit
aucun autre rédacteur en chef
journaliste présentateur de tranches n'a
jugé utile de relater ces informations
seules le présentateur du journal de la
nuit rachidem Barki
à penser que c'était des informations
qu'il devait porter à la connaissance de
son public dans le cadre de son journal
de la nuit
j'ai donc
contacter Rachid m barkil lui demander
de venir me voir il est venu me voir le
11 janvier donc 4 jours 4 jours après je
lui ai présenté les vidéos et lui
demander de quoi il en retournait
comment ces informations étaient
arrivées à l'antenne il m'a raconté
d'abord que elle était immédiatement
qu'elle lui avait été
proposé par ce qu'il décrit comme un
informateur il m'a donné le nom de
Jean-Pierre Duthion en me disant
immédiatement que Jean-Pierre Duthion
lui avait proposé un certain nombre
d'informations et que il était de son
libre arbitre journalistique de les
prendre ou pas et immédiatement il a nié
une contrepartie financière il m'a
expliqué que ces informations étaient
selon lui importante pour l'antenne je
l'ai écouté je lui ai demandé
et je lui ai dit pourquoi pas mais
pourquoi qui est au courant dans la
chaîne hiérarchique je vais vous décrire
ensuite évidemment le processus robuste
qui conduit à mettre une information à
l'antenne à BFM TV là en l'occurrence il
a donc été contourné mais dans la mesure
où il avait jugé que ces informations
devaient être dans son journal qu'elle
avait été le processus qu'il avait suivi
pour faire valider ses informations là
il a été plus qu'évasif puisque il m'a
dit que la rédactrice en chef n'avait
pas été au courant je vous décrirai pour
comment dans toutes les cas les
rédacteurs en chef valide les enfants
les informations qui passent à l'antenne
et plus problématique comme vous l'avez
vu même il y avait un certain nombre
d'images dans le cadre de ces
informations qui venaient illustrer ce
qu'il disait des images qui
n'apparaissent pas qui n'ont pas été
tournées par BFM TV qui n'ont pas été
achetés par notre cellule d'image toutes
les images diffusées à l'antenne de BFM
TV suivant process soit elles sont dans
une banque d'image soit elles ont été
tournées soit on demande qu'on les
achète mais en l'occurrence là elles ont
été ingérées à l'antenne par des images
que Rachid mbarkin n'a pas a reconnu
avoir été donné par Jean-Pierre Duthion
donc je lui ai demandé là dessus de de
préciser les choses face donc à ces
réponses et contenu de la gravité des
faits qu'il était reproché immédiatement
nous avons décidé de le suspendre de
l'antenne dispenser d'activité en lui
conservant son salaire
puisqu'il est nécessaire pour se
prévaloir de tourisme de se donner du
temps pour examiner la véracité des
incidents rapportés avant de prendre une
décision et l'écouter peut-être qu'il y
avait eu un dysfonctionnement en interne
qu'il fallait pouvoir régler et loin de
nous l'idée de l'accabler bien au
contraire mais d'écouter les choses de
façon
apaisée et encore une fois pas dans le
cadre d'une ingérence étrangère
peut-être potentiel mais en tout cas
c'était pas le sujet mon sujet en tant
que directeur général de la chaîne
c'était de comprendre comment des
informations arrivent à l'antenne sans
que personne ne soit au courant par le
présentateur qui décide de de les mettre
à long terme évidemment
j'ai averti le président du groupe
altiste le directeur de l'information
du groupe Altis aussi le directeur
gestion des risques et obligations
légales du groupe et on a décidé de
lancer un format d'investigation en
interne de deux ordres la première vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure du vin au
30 janvier un audit interne a été mené
par la Direction de l'Audit interne du
groupe donc pour examiner simplement ce
que je vous raconter si Rachid m Barki
était passé outre le processus de
validation de la ligne éditoriale
concernant ces séquences
ça te dit ces mené sur 10 jours
additionner beaucoup de personnes
contrairement à ce qui a pu raconter
hiérarchidane Barki il a été évidemment
entendu pas dans le cadre dans cette
Audi dans le cadre d'un rendez-vous où
il avait tout loisir d'expliquer les
choses ce à quoi il a refusé de le faire
ça a duré à 45 minutes environ j'étais
présent à ce rendez-vous en lui
proposant de raconter et d'expliquer
chaque séquence et chaque chaque
processus de mise à l'antenne c'est au
titre a révélé que de 2021 2022 une
douzaine de séquences donc Frédéric
metteto comme je le disais on avait
repéré 3 l'audit a validé 12 séquences
qui avaient contourné la chaîne de
production
habituelle des demandes pour arriver à
l'antenne effectuées par rachidienne par
qui est toujours à l'oral modification
ou ajout sans validation du rédacteur en
chef dans un délai toujours très tardif
très proche du journal les contusions de
l'audit ont donc montré craché avait
sciemment contourné les processus
internes que je vais encore pouvoir
développer un peu plus tout à l'heure ça
c'était donc l'audit interne a été mené
ce qui vous intéresse peut-être plus
mais c'est là-dessus que je serai
décevant une enquête interne menée de
manière indépendante par la direction de
la conformité afin de vérifier tout
élément pouvant attester des faits de
corruption passive
l'enquête interne comme vous le savez
est soumise au secret je n'y ai
personnellement pas participé pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de sujet
d'impertialité et de confidentialité il
y a tout ça
sur la base de investigation la
direction décidons mettre fin au contrat
de Rachid mbarky comme vous l'avez dit
le 21 février après qu'il est donc plus
s'expliquer pendant quasiment une heure
mais il a refusé de le faire et le
contenu de l'enquête nous a posé sur une
question pour que nous assistions nous
cessions la justice a été fait le 22
février 2023 une plainte a été déposée
au parquet pour savoir ce qui vous
intéressera plus c'est ce qui nous
intéressera aussi si oui ou non il y a
une corruption passive
dans le cadre de ce dossier ce que nous
sommes bien incapables de savoir et ce
qui n'est donc pas la raison pour
laquelle rachidam barky a été écarté de
l'antenne a été licencié pour faute
grave
le respect du processus de validation
vous l'imaginez et là ça rejoint vos
travaux est essentiel pour s'assurer que
tu sois pas diffusé à l'antenne des
informations dans l'origine n'est pas
connue n'est pas vérifié si il est
nécessaire de les accompagner
éventuellement d'y apporter des réserves
nous avons des procédures robustes et
des règles les règles d'abord pour un
journal
la ligne éditoriale est l'intégralité
des journaux sont validés intégralement
par un rédacteur en chef en amont donc
il y a un rédacteur en chef un chef
d'édition qui avant la mise en scène des
journaux valide l'ensemble des séquences
évidemment comme Rachid mbarky a pu vous
le raconter hier le journaliste est
libre de ces textes il a la compétence
il a la liberté éditoriale en revanche
le contenu du journal est intégralement
validé par par le rédacteur en chef et
si le c'est bien c'est bien son droit
puisque
les présentateurs ne sont pas que
présentateurs interviennent dans le
contenu du journal s'ils veulent en
modifier le contenu il en a la
entretien auquel je tiens pardon à
réaffirmer devant vous avec vigueur tout
mon soutien et ma confiance les les 250
journalistes qui quand ils sont arrivés
à BFM TV reçoivent une charte
déontologie très précise qui leur a été
d'ailleurs réenvoyé en 2020 et
d'ailleurs
Rachid and market était destinataire une
nouvelle fois de cette charte qui par
ailleurs est présente sur notre site
internet donc c'est quelque chose de
très de très précis de très de connu de
tous et qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut
pas me connaître
voilà
ça fait trois ans et demi que je suis à
la tête de BFM TV je travaille au
quotidien donc au sein de cette
rédaction et de avec cet ensemble de
journalistes et je peux attester ici
donc de la rigueur du respect des règles
d'anthologie pour garantir
la meilleure information possible en
tout cas notre crédibilité
pour conclure rechercher recueillir des
informations c'est donc le coeur de
notre métier il est aussi important de
les vérifier de les recouper c'est la
différence entre le le journalisme la
communication
la matière première dont nous traitons
ce sont des faits quel que soit
l'interprétation que tente de leur
donner leurs sources nous devons
absolument veiller à ne pas plier à
cette influence ne pas donner une
décennifications assez fait qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément plus encore on doit
veiller à ne pas laisser s'immiscer dans
le travail de journaliste c'est à dire
l'analyse l'appréciation la hiérarchie
une quelconque ingérence l'ingérance
pour nous c'est évidemment le contraire
c'est la négation
du journalisme un mot encore sur nos
outils qui nous permettent de faire
notre travail le mieux possible
et lutter contre la manipulation de
l'information
on a tout un process pour donner des
informations à l'antenne de double voire
de triple check des sources on a une
cellule de fact checking il arrive
d'activer une cellule de fact checking
vidéo notamment pour l'Ukraine pour
vérifier que les que les images qui nous
arrivent soit des images
pas manipuler et une formation pour
apprendre à faire checker et proposer
régulièrement et un syndrome de
journalistes de la rédaction
indépendamment de cette cellule de
fake-king il participe c'est des outils
et des process éprouvés efficients et
donc on considère que notre process
quand il n'est pas contourné sciemment
et robuste pour conclure BFM vous l'avez
compris et victime dans cette affaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
agi rapidement avec sévérité et que nous
avons déposé plainte et je suis
maintenant disponible pour répondre à
vos questions
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
Fogiel pour cette exposé très clair
écoutez juste à titre préliminaire la
commission n'attend rien elle n'est pas
déçue par vos déclarations
notre commission a essayé de comprendre
un phénomène qui est apparu dans les
médias de faire le travail de
représentant du peuple on n'attend pas
spécialement de nourrir des polémiques
ou d'avoir des des choses
c'est pas une mise en cause rétabli le
cadre de nos travaux qui sont
parfaitement sereins et nous sommes
déçus par absolument rien la question
que je veux bien comprendre
rédacteur en chef et chef d'édition
c'est pareil non rédacteur en chef c'est
donc quelqu'un qui valide une initoriale
c'est quelqu'un qui a en charge le
contenu éditorial d'une du d'une tranche
un chef un chef d'édition c'est des
échelons au dessous c'est c'est un poste
journalistique et technique mais c'est
pas pareil le chef d'édition ou le chef
d'information ensuite réfère un
rédacteur en chef
il y a une chaîne hiérarchique il y a
des échelons et à la tête de la chaîne
hiérarchique il y a le rédacteur en chef
qui lui-même réfère après un directeur
adjointe rédaction un directeur de
rédaction et à moi-même
très bien merci pour cette précision
pour bien comprendre les le processus
que vous avez que vous avez décrit si
j'ai bien compris les éléments que vous
avez indiqué suite à l'audit interne que
vous avez réalisé il semble donc à vos
yeux monsieur et merki donc t'as pas
respecté les procédures robustes que
vous aviez mis en place mais aussi c'est
qu'il est bien compris a choisi ces
moments vous avez visiblement si j'ai
bien compris pour pas qu'il y ait
sous-entendu parce que le but aussi de
cette commission c'est qui est jamais de
sous-entendu qui sont à la libre
appréciation de ceux qui nous écoutent
et parfois de manière malveillante
évidemment ce serait donc pour vous
qu'il a aussi choisi ces moments s'il y
a des moments peut-être une personne
n'était pas présente ça peut arriver
dans n'importe quel organisation humaine
ou d'avoir
donc volontairement de manière donc
organisée donc choisi ces moments où il
pouvait diffuser c'est reportages il est
vrai qu'à certain nombre de reportages
et si vous pouvez nous le confirmer
aussi un peu intemporel il y avait deux
catégories de de de off s'il est bien
compris des offres qui avaient une
actualité par exemple un une un
séminaire économique entre le Maroc et
l'Espagne il y avait un moment pour
lequel le diffuser mais aussi
visiblement des offres général par
exemple un document sur la sécurité
rétablie au Cameroun je crois on aurait
pu visiblement diffuser à n'importe quel
moment enfin n'importe quel moment sur
une période large est-ce que les
éléments que je viens vous indiquer vous
paraissent correct est-ce que vous
pouvez repréciser la méthode de la
méthode alors plusieurs choses pour
pouvoir vous répondre monsieur le
Président il s'agit pas de reportage à
chaque fois il s'agit de séquences très
courtes d'une quinzaine voire d'une
vingtaine de secondes si j'ai pas de
reportage donc de ce que on appelle dans
notre jargon des brèves ou des offres
mais en aucun cas de reportage qui
aurait
sous-entendu un travail journalistique
en amont fait par des équipes c'est
simplement de l'illustration de de
textes qu'il a été amené à lire mais
donc pas un travail journalistique en
amont fait par quelqu'un d'autre et pour
répondre à votre question sur le
compteur notamment et le choix des
moments oui c'était pas des moments où
il y a personne puisqu'il y a toujours
quelqu'un mais les rédacteurs en chef
sont sur plusieurs tranches donc
toujours quand le rédacteur en chef
était occupé à autre chose pendant ce
moment-là est toujours en dernière
minute et souvent avec des chefs
d'édition par exemple qui était pas des
titulaires et qui Rachid embarquis est
un grand professionnel qui est à
l'antenne de BFM depuis ses débuts donc
il y a une forme de crédibilité par
rapport à des jeunes rédacteurs chef
d'édition qui était là ce soir là et
quand il leur demande de faire ça
ils le font
je vous mets par rapport à l'intention
l'intemporalité ou pas c'est quand même
des séquences qui sont à chaque fois
ancrées dans dans l'actualité on a parlé
relevé de fausses séquences des
séquences qui avaient ou pas leur place
sur BFM TV des séquences à tiroirs pas
toujours compréhensibles qui
pour le commun des mortel en les
écoutant on comprenait pas trop mais en
revanche elles étaient liées à chaque
fois à une actualité à quelque chose qui
était réel il n'y a pas il n'a pas été
donné à l'antenne de fausses
informations des informations qui
n'avaient pas leur place qui était
peut-être orienté ou en tout cas
incompréhensible mettant en cause sur
l'un certaines d'entre elles des gens
mais pas mais rien de ce qui a été dit
n'était faux n'a pas été inventé de
l'information de l'information qui ne
trouvait pas sa place sur sur l'antenne
de BFM TV mais pas de fausses séquence
ce qui me paraît important à signaler à
signaler ici il n'y a pas de la fausse
information d'ailleurs ce qui ne
justifie pas de démentir une information
qui aurait été donnée ce qu'on aurait
fait volontiers c'est avec le cas ce qui
a été dit n'a pas d'intérêt selon nous
selon notre inéditoriale et n'a pas de
n'a pas de sens dans dans le cadre de
notre format mais n'est pas en soi faux
même si certaines sont contestables dans
leur formulation
oui je vous remercie effectivement c'est
c'est une information importante par
rapport à ce qui était déclaré à
l'audition de Monsieur mbarqué la
question et vous vous êtes revenu
plusieurs reprises dessus je ne sais pas
si c'est par rapport à l'audition d'hier
ou si c'était déjà prévu dans dans votre
propos
ça n'a pas d'importance sur la question
des images la finement la nature des
images qui ont été présentées à
l'antenne on a posé les commissaires ont
posé plusieurs questions à Monsieur mcki
sur effectivement le fait est-ce qu'il
avait diffusé des images qui avait été
fournies par Monsieur Duthion si c'était
inquiété du coup que ces images avaient
eu pour Monsieur Duthion et donc de
l'opportunité de diffuser des images
n'était pas tomber du ciel de la façon
dont effectivement c'était traitée
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne s'était pas
servi de la banque d'image de de BFM TV
ou d'image dont il aurait pu demander
l'achat donc visiblement une question
assise vous pourrez confirmer que BFM TV
ou pas que BFM TV peut acheter des
images aussi il manque des images qui
sont pas à la disposition cette banque
il est tout à fait possible d'en
acquérir dans un délai dans un délai
raisonnable et aussi de l'absence et ça
je voulais avoir votre avis sur la
procédure qui est menée par BFM TV sur
l'identification des sources des images
qui sont diffusées à votre antenne quand
ces images ne viennent pas de la
rédaction de BFMTV ou ne viennent pas
d'une banque IMAX que vous avez fait
est-ce qu'il y a systématiquement la
source qui est mentionnée ou est-ce que
c'est un peu c'est c'est à la discrétion
de la rédaction ou du moment où j'avais
évidemment prévu de vous parler de ce
contournement de la règle importante
avec ces images puisque c'est en sac
c'est un préjudice important pour
l'antenne de BFM TV le fait de
contourner les règles sur des images
j'ai pas attendu l'audition d'hier pour
pour le stipuler puisque c'est dans la
lettre de licenciement de de rachim
embarki ces images
ces images en question
j'allais dire d'abord peu importe la
source mais d'un point de vue simplement
légal quand une image passe sur une
antenne de télévision il faut en des
droits donc
on ne passe pas des images même par
exemple je prends un exemple d'actualité
d'aujourd'hui si on découvre par exemple
sur Twitter des images de manifestation
qui nous semblent intéressantes on passe
pas ces images comme ça
au-delà de la question d'anthologie qui
nous importe d'abord mais elle nous
appartiennent pas à ces images donc si
on voulait le faire il faudrait
contacter la personne qui les publie lui
demander l'autorisation éventuellement
les usages les acheter donc les images
mises à long terme dans le cadre des
séquences problématiques pour certaines
d'entre elles puisque certaines sont
illustrées par des images que l'on avait
puisque c'est des images prétexte
d'autres ont été mises à l'antenne de
façon délibérée puisqu'il n'existait pas
de choses pour d'images chez nous pour
illustrer ces images ont été rajoutées
par Rachid m Barki et nous avons la
preuve dans le cadre de l'audit qu'elles
ont été fournies par Jean-Pierre Duthion
donc ça c'est c'est la première chose
c'était je pense pas avoir répondu
complètement à votre question il pourra
plus globalement les images qui vont à
l'antenne de BFM TV nous avons une
cellule documentation une cellule ce
qu'on appelle news corde et donc
l'ensemble des images qui vont l'antenne
de BFM TV sans aucune exception sont
toutes certifiées de temps en temps
d'ailleurs par la cellule de fake
checking que nous montons par moment
quand nous avons des doutes mais aucune
image n'arrive à l'antenne de façon
fortuite et sans savoir d'où elles
viennent et quand nous avons des doutes
par exemple ça s'est passé sur la guerre
en Ukraine ou il y a eu des mises en
scène organisées dans le cadre de de la
riposte
ukrainienne et nous précisons en quoi
nous pensons qu'à l'avant qu'elles ont
un sens journalistique de les diffuser
en émettant les doutes sur une
éventuelle reconstitution des scènes en
l'occurrence à l'époque par l'armée
ukrainienne donc
il nous arrive de diffuser des images
comme celle là pour lequel nous avons
des doutes sur la Véra cité du moment
mais nous l'expliquons parce que c'est
un sens journalistique donc voilà mais
donc pour répondre à votre question oui
c'est pas
c'est pas une télé artisanale c'est une
rédaction qui compte 250 journalistes et
des cellules de documentation ou de
newscore qui en compte qui sont des
journalistes qui comptent
une vingtaine de journalistes dédiés
qu'à ça
je vous remercie ma dernière question
avant de faire tourner la parole
sur le cas de ce monsieur Duthion donc
est-ce que vous vous le connaissiez ce
que vous aviez déjà entendu parler des
de son rôle de lobbyiste dans la
formation française est-ce que vous
c'est un nom qui vous dit quelque chose
ou est-ce que vous l'avez et c'est une
question ouverte c'est pas une question
piège le tiens à préciser est-ce que
c'est la première fois que vous
entendiez parler de de Monsieur Duthion
et du rôle qu'il aurait pu avoir auprès
de Monsieur imberki personnellement
c'est la première fois que j'en ai
entendu parler c'est pas le cas de la
rédaction de BFM TV moi je suis là
depuis 2019 mais dans le cadre du
Printemps arabe au tout départ et c'est
comme ça qu'il s'est fait connaître
comme il a été utilisé en tant que fixer
au tout début en Syrie très peu de temps
mais c'est un nom qui était pas
totalement étranger pour certains
journalistes qui avaient déjà eu affaire
à lui dans le passé très lointain
mais donc comme fixeur de vos équipes
de beaucoup d'équipes à l'époque en 2013
me semble-t-il mais pas comme
fournisseur comme source d'information
jamais je vous remercie madame moi je ne
connais pas personnellement à partir
peut-être que dans les informations
qu'il est amené à proposer comme
d'autres dans le cadre de l'influence
des choses peuvent peut-être nous
intéresser j'en sais rien en tout cas un
travail journalistique doit être fait
derrière et recouper et je veux pas
discréditer ce monsieur que je ne
connais pas a priori
mais peut-être que dans les informations
qui les supposées proposées enfin
formation élément d'information des
choses peuvent être intéressantes j'en
sais rien en tout cas je veux pas le
discréditer a priori
je remercie madame la rapporteur votre
micro s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Fogiel merci pour les explications que
vous nous avez données nous comprenons
donc un peu mieux je crois en tout cas
votre point de vue sur les étapes très
précises des process de validation
temporaire les images que pour les choix
des sujets et cela vaut donc également
pour les offres qui sont évidemment des
petits sujets si je puis dire qui ne
donne pas lieu à des reportages de
nature journalistique qui sont un autre
type de format peut-être voilà plus
resserré et plus court et donc
susceptible de venir en fin de journal
et peut-être à certains égards
considérés comme étant de moindres
importantes mais qui néanmoins voilà
justement parce que je rebondis par
rapport à une expression qui avait été
employée hier prendre important parce
qu'il peut y avoir des offres très
importants et qui viennent en début de
journal c'est pas une information de
deuxième classe qu'on mettra à la fin
pour égayer un journal c'est simplement
c'est pas particulièrement développé
mais ça ne dit rien de l'importance de
l'information ça
dans le cas de ce journal la façon si on
le traite sur la longueur ou pas mais
rien de l'importance de l'information
qui est donnée il y a des offres qui
peuvent être légers qui sont des fins de
journal d'ailleurs une des séquences en
l'occurrence reprochée et celle-là
puisque on parle d'un hôtel à Madagascar
qui a reçu le prix du meilleur hôtel du
monde ou quelque chose comme ça et donc
Rachid mbarky termine son journal avec
cette information que pas partir mon
problématique mais qui nous semble pas
très importantes mais bon celle-là n'a
pas n'a pas il y a des il y a des offres
qui apparaissent beaucoup plus tôt dans
le journal mais qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
développés mais qui qui ne sont pas des
séquences anecdotiques ou plus légères
merci c'est
très important de nos travaux de ceux
qui sont notamment à l'extérieur de la
séance il faut bien que l'intervenant
est bien fini sa question de manière et
voilà et vous ne pouvez pas
m'interrompre même si vous avez envie et
là
voilà c'est un peu la spécificité de des
assemblées la parole est un peu plus
lente que sur un autre endroit donc il
faut bien il faut bien que
la question de votre de du commissaire
soit bien clairement achevé pour que
vous puissiez reprendre la parole et
même si j'étais très procédure à ce que
je ne suis pas il faudrait même que
entre les deux je vous redonne la parole
donc vraiment pour la clarté de
l'audition laissez bien elle apporter
aux autres commissaires bien finir leurs
questions surtout vous êtes une
personnalité donc ne sous-estimez pas
l'importance que vous avez
bien c'est précision ayant été apporté
mais voilà ce que ce que vous dites
s'agissant du statut et du de
l'importance entre guillemets des offres
et et tout à fait je pense essentiel
pour pour comprendre un centre de choses
et qui n'ont absolument pas dans leur
conception dans leur passage d'antenne à
échapper en aucune manière au process de
validation mise en place tant pour les
images que pour les textes bien bien
évidemment vous nous avez dit donc les
différentes investigations avaient
permis de révéler 12 offs qui
pouvait à certains égards j'essaie de
reprendre vos
formules peuvent être contestables dans
leur formulation
et n'avait rien à voir avec la ligne
éditoriale est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un tout petit peu plus alors moi
j'ai pas connaissance à vous de 12
sujets on a esquissé quelques-uns mais
j'avais pas je n'ai pas le panorama
complet des 12 sujets ou des 12 offs et
pouvez nous dire en quoi
ces sujets ou c'est offs sont
contestables dans leur formulation n'ont
rien à voir avec la ligne éditoriale de
BFM TV et ce qu'est la ligne éditoriale
de BFM TV
tout d'abord je m'excuse de vous avoir
interrompu on se refait pas mais
j'essaye de faire des efforts pourtant
concernant donc
c'est 12 séquences en elle-même
en quoi elles sont pas dans la ligne de
bfmte d'abord en quoi elles sont elles
sont contestables c'est que quand on
écoute un certain nombre d'entre elles
on ne comprend pas le sens de ce qui est
on comprend le début de l'information et
ensuite il y a des références à des gens
notamment pour une d'entre elles un
blogueur britannique notamment où on ne
saisit pas le propre du journalisme
c'est plutôt de d'être en intermédiaire
pour essayer de faire passer une
information et faire comprendre une
information là c'est précisément
l'inverse et notamment dans les offres
c'est très compliqué off en fait puisque
c'est c'est comme une brève dans un
journal on a l'impression que c'est rien
au contraire c'est ça demande un effort
particulier puisqu'il faut synthétiser
encore plus une information et qu'elle
soit compréhensible à tous là l'effet de
certains de ces offres étaient inverse
il y a des références que le commun des
téléspectateurs ne peut pas saisir ne
pas comprendre l'occurrence en parlant
de gens qui ne sont absolument pas
identifiés
ce n'est pas intelligible donc ça pour
en tout cas pour un certain nombre de
ces informations qui a été qui ont été
données à l'antenne ensuite sur les 12
séquences je pourrais vous faire passer
si vous voulez je les ai pas là la liste
parce qu'elle est elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas secrète mais en gros c'est des
séquences qui ne concernent
pour certains des oligarques russes pour
d'autres
des pays d'Afrique ou du Moyen-Orient
essentiellement
et enfin cet hôtel à Madagascar
oui merci vous nous aviez dit que vous
n'aviez pas entendu parler en tout cas
vous ne connaissiez pas personnellement
monsieur monsieur Duthion mais que
d'autres avaient déjà eu dans le passé
bien avant votre arrivée à BFM TV à
connaître de ces activités de fixeur
notamment pendant le printemps arabe
est-ce qu'à votre connaissance qu'on
révélé les enquêtes internes est-ce que
d'autres journalistes
de BFMTV ont pu être je dirais récemment
enfin depuis qu'il n'est plus fixeur
mais qu'il est lobbiste
ou spécialiste de de l'influence ont pu
être approchés contacté d'une manière ou
d'une autre par Monsieur Duthion à votre
connaissance
j'ai attendu la fin là
monsieur Duthion a essayé de contacter
d'autres journalistes de BFM TV après le
départ de Rachid Mbarki
puisque ces journalistes me l'ont
signalé mais aucune information n'a été
donnée à l'antenne par son intermédiaire
mais oui monsieur Duthion une fois que
Rachid lemarki a été écarté de l'antenne
à contacter d'autres journalistes de BFM
TV pour leur proposer d'autres types
entre guillemets d'informations qui
n'ont pas suscité ça leur intérêt
et je peux préciser ici je les fais sous
serment ça vaut pour un de ces
journalistes qu'il a révélé dans le
cadre de l'enquête interne lui a été
proposé à ce moment-là une rétribution
je ne dis pas ici que Rachida a été
rétribué j'en ai absolument aucune aucun
élément même si ou même si ça lui a été
proposé je n'en sais rien ce que je sais
dans le cadre de l'en-tête interne en
tout cas de préciser un journaliste
contacté après le départ de Rachid
Mbarki il a été contacté par Jean-Pierre
Duthion et Jean-Pierre Duthion lui a
proposé une rétribution contre une
information qu'il n'a pas jugé utile
d'abord évidemment pas la rétribution et
l'information de passer à l'antenne
c'est dans le c'est précisé dans le
cadre de l'antenne interne de
l'auditante
c'est tout à fait
important de le savoir mais pas de
d'autres cas de tentatives d'approche de
tenter de contact avant c'est c'est
dernière année
non madame la rapporteur
contenu du sujet qui intéresse notre
commission d'enquête les risques
d'ingérence étrangères dans la sphère
politique ou dans la sphère médiatique
de manière générale est-ce qu'il y a
par-delà la charte de déontologie etc
une une
sensibilisation une formation
dispensée
régulièrement à l'intérieur de BFM TV
par exemple au journaliste sur les
risques d'ingérence étrangère
particulièrement à manipulation
deep fake images etc etc tronqué ou
manipuler ça on conçoit très bien que ça
fasse partie des
formations et des sensibilisations
dispensées mais sur le risque
d'ingérence étrangère particulièrement
pas précisément sur la gérance étrangère
sur le Deep fake etc évidemment il y a
des formations qui sont proposées sur
l'ingérence étrangère perpétuellement
mais notre système de vérification de
l'information de la façon dont elle est
mise à long terme la hiérarchie qui est
mise en place c'est qu'une information
d'où qu'elle vienne et pour n'importe
quel raison n'arrive pas à l'antenne
sans être checker être pesé être
réfléchi donc je ne sais pas si c'est de
l'ingérence au départ mais en tout cas
il y a combien même ça on serait elle
n'arrive pas à elle n'arrive pas à
l'antenne comme ça sur la base de la
décision d'une personne tout ça et
rentre dans une chaîne qui fait que ça
ne doit pas pouvoir arriver
sauf quand les règles sont contournées
volontairement
dernière question parce que finalement
il faut faire tourner la parole est-ce
que à la suite des investigations et
audit interne de cette affaire entre
guillemets
vous avez envisagé ou vous avez déjà
mise en place des modifications ou les
renforcements ou des ou des robustes se
renforcés je dirais des différents
process de validation
on a rappelé les règles à chacun mais
les règles sont robustes solides et ne
doivent pas permettre
il n'y a pas d'interstice possible sauf
encore une fois qu'on décide d'aller
répondre des contourner mais c'est lors
de la décision personnelle donc il y a
pas de raison après audit et après
réflexion de renforcer un dispositif qui
est solide et robuste
merci madame le rapporteur madame
Colombier
oui j'imagine que en plus de vos
reportages j'allais dire interne interne
réalisé en interne vous avez bien sûr ce
que j'appellerais peut-être des
informations ou d'autres lobbystes c'est
ça semble pas du tout aberrant donc
est-ce que dans ce cadre-là est-ce que
vous n'êtes peut-être pas là depuis tant
d'années mais je dirais ce que il y a
pas est-ce qu'il arrive est-ce qu'il
peut arriver que certaines personnes
puissent être rémunérées pour une
information qu'il vous donne et qui
passerait ensuite à l'antenne même sans
que ce soit quelque chose
mais que vous le sachiez voilà pas de
façon anonyme
donc là si j'ai bien compris la question
c'est l'inverse c'est pas un journaliste
qui serait rétribué pour faciles
informations mais c'est un informateur
qu'on aurait payé pour qu'il nous donne
une information
la charte dedansologie est très claire
c'est impossible nous n'achetons pas
d'informations
je peux prendre un exemple récent
et précis
par exemple dans le cadre de cette
affaire dites Palmade en informateur
nous a appelé nous a proposé de donner
des images
compromettantes nous ne l'avons demandé
très attribué pour ça évidemment nous
n'avons pas fait
merci Monsieur Chenu
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général est-ce que vous aviez
déjà été dans le passé confronté à ce
type de problème tant sur BFM que vous
dirigez depuis 3 ans et demi que tout au
long de dire il y a d'autres postes de
votre longue et brillante carrière et
comment se prémunir justement de ce type
d'éventuelles tentative d'influence
qu'elle soit étrangère ou d'ordre privé
d'ailleurs
merci monsieur le député non c'est la
première fois que je suis confronté dans
le cadre de mon parcours professionnel à
ce type de contournement des règles et
comment se prémunir en étant un bon
journaliste
assez simplement
en respectant une charte de déontologie
en faisant des choses pour des raisons
précises dans une chaîne hiérarchique on
se demandant le sens de l'information
qu'on veut donner voilà et
je peux pas dire autre chose qu'en étant
bon journaliste
merci monsieur
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur Monsieur le Directeur Général
bon j'arrive un peu après la bataille
mes collègues ont déjà posé pas mal de
questions mais c'est vrai que je voulais
je me demandais comment est-ce qu'un
présentateur effectivement a les moyens
techniques de rentrer dans la machine
c'est c'est documentaires alors je pense
que vous avez un peu répondu en disant
que finalement il avait une certaine
autorité naturelle qui faisait que quand
il disait à quelqu'un de le dire on le
faisait parce que c'était lui donc vous
répondrez voilà mais je pense que j'ai
bien compris et effectivement je pense
que quand on est patron de chaîne ce
risque d'ingérence où il y avait
sûrement déjà pensé avant évidemment
avant que cette enquête arrive et est-ce
que justement est-ce que c'est nombreux
process est-ce que finalement trop de
process tue pas le process et que et que
l'ingérence peut quand même arriver
justement malgré toutes ces j'allais
dire toutes ces vérifications et quels
sont les règles effectivement qui
peuvent être mises en en place
maintenant j'allais dire pour sécuriser
vos journalistes pour faire en sorte que
leur intégrité ne soit pas corrompu par
ces fameux lobbyistes dont parler madame
la rapporteur je vous remercie
merci Madame la député concernant donc
le début de la question non pour être
bien clair ce n'est pas rachidam Barki
lui-même qui a rentré des images dans
une dans un ordinateur il a contribué à
travers vous l'avez mieux dites-moi
d'ailleurs son autorité naturelle et à
travers ce jour-là des jeunes
journalistes souvent pas titulaires
il leur a demandé de le faire
et donc en contournant une génération
puisque tout ça doit être fait
normalement via le rédacteur en chef
donc ça c'est la première aspect de de
la de la question après il y a des
règles elles sont claires elles sont
rappelées après comme partout si vous
voulez les contourner
ça vaut pour l'information ça vaut dans
tous les domaines et dans toutes les
sociétés vous avez toujours le loisir de
le faire et heureusement d'être appelé à
l'ordre comme c'est le cas là en
l'occurrence depuis 15 ans que BFM TV
existe sous l'autorité d'Hervé roux
d'abord aujourd'hui sous ma direction
avec Hervé roux à côté
ça n'est jamais arrivé qu'à travers ce
journal de la nuit avec quelqu'un qui
délivre vraiment a décidé de les
contourner ses règles
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général
j'aurai une d'autres types de questions
que celles que je vous ai posé au début
de notre audition enfin après votre
exposé le suivi de l'ingérence et vous
vous le savez en tant que professionnel
à émerger dans le débat politique des
grandes démocraties occidentales depuis
depuis plusieurs années
alors il y a toujours un phénomène qui
est propre à
tout le monde que ça n'arrive qu'aux
autres c'est pas du tout une critique
mais est-ce que ça s'inscrit un peu dans
la question que vous avez posé même le
rapporteur mais de manière peut-être une
réponse plus à la plus large peut-être
plus explicite est-ce que le risque
quand même d'ingérence c'est-à-dire le
fait que vos journalistes quel que soit
leur intégrité personnelle et leur
professionnalisme ou à travers des
stagiaires enfin peut-être à moi j'ai
travaillé dans l'industrie le un risque
non qui peut paraître minime et qui
était réel c'est l'infiltration par des
stagiaires qui sont pas vraiment des
stagiaires mais il est impossible à une
entreprise privée d'établir des
vérifications comme pour faire des
services de l'État évidemment
donc est-ce que le risque d'ingérence
au-delà du fait que vous en parlez à
l'antenne et que c'est un sujet qu'on
dont on parle est-ce que vraiment et
sincèrement c'est un sujet qui
préoccupait votre rédaction qui au-delà
de la charte de déontologie qui existe
et des procédures quand vous avez parlé
a été intégré est-ce que ça vous avez a
été amené à rajouter des étapes à
rajouter des process de vérification que
ce soit dans votre travail éditorial
journalistique ou que dans vos
procédures ressources humaines
il y a un peu plusieurs choses dedans
enfin dans ma réponse pendant votre
question il y a l'ingérence il y a
l'influence
l'influence et donc les journalistes qui
travaillent dans la rédaction de BFM TV
comme dans les autres rédactions
importantes et solides elles sont
contactes tous les jours et c'est même
leur travail avec des sources des
sources qui ont des intérêts à faire
passer des informations et en ça c'est
pas condamnable
il y a des gens qui viennent vous voir
ou que vous sollicitez qui vous donne
des informations plus ou moins
pertinentes et à vous de juger
journalistiquement en quoi elles peuvent
éclairer le grand public sur sur un fait
d'actualité donc
couper des journalistes de leur source
qui elle-même ont peut-être des intérêts
pourquoi pas d'ingérence ou d'influence
ça n'aurait pas de sens c'est couper la
une partie de l'information après le
travail journalistique c'est justement
de comprendre quel est l'intérêt
recouper voir ce qu'il y a derrière et
essayer de comprendre quel intérêt ça
peut servir éventuellement et donc ça
revient c'est ce que je répondais au
député chenilles tout à l'heure ça
revient quand je dis bonjour analyse
c'est cette c'est ce travail là qui qui
aujourd'hui à BFM télé pour avoir vécu
dans d'autres rédactions aussi
importantes est une rédaction quand tout
à l'heure je l'ai qualifié c'était pas
pour la forme
exemplaire ce travail là il est fait par
des gens et par des et par du temps et
par du nombre de 150 journalistes dans
une rédaction c'est c'est pas rien nous
avons les moyens de ça donc pour
répondre à votre question l'influence
voir l'ingérence parce que c'est le
mauvais côté éventuellement de
l'influence ça d'une certaine
donc contactez des journalistes leur
proposer des choses
et essayer de les influencer d'une façon
ou d'une autre pour des bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons en soi c'est la vie de
tous les jours et je trouve rien
derrière sauf derrière un travail
journalistique fait par des gens
compétents et qui ont les capacités de
savoir si ce qui leur est proposé à un
intérêt comment le contextualiser et
sert quel intérêt et éventuellement le
raconter donc la réponse à cette
question là et puis ensuite il y a un
autre rôle c'est que comment
lutter entre guillemets mais c'est pas
le terme c'est comment
affronter
correctement ces sources d'information
quand je répondais mais c'était pas une
pirouette à Monsieur Chenu sur en étant
bon journaliste il faut avoir des moyens
pour ça BFM TV on a il faut recruter des
journalistes compétents ce qu'on essaye
de faire tous les jours et j'en ai la
preuve aux quotidien et avoir une
charnière archite non pas simplement de
validation de réflexion il y a des
choses où on se pose la question en
permanence de l'intérêt des choses il
nous arrive d'ailleurs de nous tromper
heureusement pas souvent mais ça peut
nous arriver sur l'intérêt d'une
information d'une information donc c'est
l'ensemble de cet écosystème qui est
robuste qui permet de
lutter contre la mauvaise influence voir
l'ingérence ensuite par rapport à ce que
vous dites l'infiltration dans une
rédaction d'éléments qui
aurait été télécommandé de l'extérieur
voilà le process de recrutement fait que
on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une erreur
mais ça n'arrive pas après si vous
parlez d'un stagiaire le stagiaire il a
pas accès à l'antenne il a pas enfin le
système que je vous décris fait que
quand bien même un stagiaire aurait été
je ne crois jamais arriver mais en tout
cas il n'aurait pas la liberté d'influer
sur la ligne éditoriale de de la chaîne
la structure est suffisamment solide
pour que
ça ne puisse pas ça ne puisse pas
arriver
je vous remercie dans la prolongation de
ma question et évidemment dans le
respect de la dépendance de la presse et
des médias de notre démocratie est-ce
que ces dernières années vous avez été
sensibilisés par les services de l'État
qui assurent la protection nos intérêts
mais aussi la qualité de notre
démocratie c'est pas évidemment pas de
volonté de venir
s'infiltrer dans vos process ou de vous
dire comment vous voulez travailler mais
une sensibilisation à ces enjeux
d'ingérence d'influence de nouvelles
modalités de la façon qu'il pouvait
frapper par exemple le fait qu'on aurait
pu vous informer qu'il existait des
entreprises avant en quête des story
killers des entreprises qui proposaient
à des journalistes ou des relais
d'opinion à travers le monde des
reportages clés en main ou une volonté
d'influencer l'information est-ce que
vous avez été sensibilisé par des
acteurs éthiques
alors pas précisément sur sur cette
société dont je n'avais pas connaissance
mais il nous arrive régulièrement et moi
en premier chef mais pas que de
d'échanger avec
les services de l'État et pour certains
que vous avez auditionné dans la
confidentialité sur
tel type par exemple
d'individus qui nous propose des choses
pour savoir s'il était si ça leur disait
quelque chose donc on a des échanges
réguliers mais pas très fréquent mais
régulier
quand on a des doutes sur des choses ou
eux-mêmes
veulent nous signifier des choses oui
c'est des échanges offres réguliers ça
arrive et sans interventionnisme jamais
mais en bonne collaboration
je vous remercie parce que évidemment
pour les pardon excusez-moi c'est vous
qui je rigole concernant notamment
concernant concernant notamment puisque
c'est un autre élément important me
semble-t-il c'est les experts il y a
beaucoup d'experts sur les télévisions
certains peuvent servir des
intérêts qu'on ne connaîtrait pas donc
il m'est arrivé à plusieurs reprises
de solliciter les services de l'État
pour avoir des informations que je
n'aurais pas sur certains experts
potentiels pour savoir s'ils étaient
aussi
exemples de de d'accusation possible
oui parce que hier monsieur mbarky à la
question que je lui posait de savoir si
en tant que journaliste il avait été
sensibilisé ces dernières années par
par sa hiérarchie ou par des services
extérieurs nous a indiqué que non de
qu'est-ce que c'est ce que vous avez
entendu cette cette question d'hier et
la réponse à question donc bah ma
question c'était un peu similaire à
celle que je vous ai posé sauf que c'est
son point de vue d'employer de BFM TV et
de journalistes français donc de savoir
s'il avait été sensibilisé donc vous de
votre point de vue aussi de manager de
dirigeant est-ce que vous avez
l'impression ces dernières années compte
tenu de la menace grandissante
d'intérence quelle qu'elle soit ou de
tentative d'ingérence est-ce que vous
vous avez en interne au-delà de la
Charte déontologie que dont vous avez
déjà parlé des processus robustes dont
vous avez que vous avez établi est-ce
que vous avez dit on va re sensibiliser
nos journalistes à ce risque qu'on va
les informer peut-être de nouvelles
formes de risques est-ce que c'est une
démarche que vous avez eu une fois plus
c'est une question ouverte il s'agit pas
de faire le procès qui compte
il y a pas de il y a pas de comment dire
de formation particulière et dédiée mais
c'est des discussions permanentes en
fait ce qui vous occupe aujourd'hui ça
nous occupe en permanence de savoir d'où
vient l'information comment elle nous
est amené ce que elle a un intérêt qu'on
ne voit pas etc donc c'est discussions
là et c'est très flexion là parce que
discussion ça fait un peu au coin de au
coin d'un bistrot non c'est autour de
table de rédaction avec des chefs de
services c'est des discussions des
réflexions des organisations régulières
donc ça se fait au fil de l'eau tout ça
en fait et puis après sur des choses
spécifiques vous parlez tout à l'heure
par exemple de Deep fake qui peut être
un instrument de l'ingérence par exemple
là oui sur des choses techniques par
exemple il y a une sensibilisation
particulière ou des formations
particulières mais cette réflexion
commune est globale sur finalement de
comment être à la bonne distance des
choses et comment ne pas être
instrumentalisé ou voir Pierre c'est une
discussion
réflexion quotidienne
il faut merci
une dernière question que je voudrais
vous poser
en tant que j'imagine aussi dirigeant de
BFM TV vous êtes attentif à l'image de
votre chaîne évidemment mais aussi
potentiellement sans doute à
l'utilisation qu'elle peut être faite
sur les réseaux sociaux le fait qu'on
utilise que certains rôles et d'opinion
en particulier donc des puissances
étrangères ou des relais de puissance
étrangères ou des cabinets d'influence
enfin tout ce qui peut exister de ce
genre de milieu puisse isoler des
passages de votre antenne isoler des
interventions de vos journalistes ils
ont lu même peut-être même votre image
personnelle en tant que personnalité
francophone reconnue dans beaucoup
beaucoup de territoires
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
surveillé par BFM TV c'est à dire de
vérifier si des images à vous sont
découpées utilisées manipuler par des
officines qui auraient pu par exemple
une fois plus c'est une question
d'accueil c'est pour comprendre qui
aurait peut-être pu vous alerter
justement sur les pratiques dont on a
parlé puisque visiblement c'est bout de
de de off ont été ont été utilisés ces
ont été utilisés ça c'est la justice
qu'il prouvera non pas pour leur
diffusion à une heure tardive de la nuit
mais pour leur
réutilisation leur valorisation dans
d'autres médias utilisant votre image et
l'autorité de votre chaîne
pour vous répondre là dessus puisqu'il
évidemment c'est des choses qui nous
préoccupent au quotidien la rédaction de
BFM TV elle est composée d'une rédaction
broadcast et d'une rédaction digitale
sous l'autorité de Julia Mel carac
aujourd'hui cette rédaction digitale
elle comporte
plus d'une centaine de journalistes
et avec des spécialistes évidemment des
sujets notamment des technologies donc
oui ces journalistes au-delà de produire
de l'information pour des digital elle
surveille le digital et donc quand
des images de BFM TV sont utilisées et
que de façon massive ou qu'elles sont
mal utilisées
tout ça remonte et signalé en
l'occurrence dans les séquences dont
vous faites allusion elles ont été
utilisées la preuve en est mais pas de
façon massive pas suffisamment
importante selon notre
c’était en dessous de la ligne de
flottaison en gros ça a servi des
intérêts précis j'imagine l'enquête le
dira ou pas d'ailleurs mais de façon
très locale mais pour répondre plus
globalement et pas sur ça puisque
l'enquête le dira mais oui il y a un
système de vigilance d'utilisation des
images de BFM TV dans le cas par et de
détournement des images de BFM TV et ça
en toutes les semaines on regarde
précisément il y a des remontées de
sujets problématiques concrètes et qu'on
gère
et dans ce cadre là donc par quand ça
dépasse la ligne que les lignes d'alerte
que vous avez fixées avec vos équipes ou
qui ont été fixées avec vos équipes
est-ce que vous êtes déjà intervenus
justement sur des cas d'espèces alors
pas obligé de nous les décrire dans le
détail mais sur peut-être leur typologie
vous êtes dit là l'image de BFM TV est
utilisée par des gens qui font de la
manipulation de l'information de la
gérance ou qui essaye de nous faire dire
ce qu'on a pas voulu dire ou de
valoriser des intérêts qui sont pas ce
qu'on voulait servir à savoir la
formation du public est-ce que c'est
voilà est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu à agir
intervenir et questions subsidiaire
est-ce que parfois la manipulation était
telle que vous l'avez signalé au service
dans le respect des moments de la
confidentialité de nos échanges que vous
avez signalé au service avec qui vous
êtes en contact de manière informelle
pour répondre à la fin de votre question
non ça n'a pas ça n'a pas été toutes les
fois précédentes oui mais d'ailleurs il
suffit de regarder où le site où notre
site Twitter général quand ça devient
préjudiciable déjà sur notre site ou sur
nos réseaux sociaux on réembête nos
images ou leur ou la façon dont elles
ont été utilisées
pardon et si vous pouvez préciser le
thème de Ryan bed s'il vous plaît c'est
reprendre pardon reprendre
un tweet par exemple leur remettre un
tweet le remettre sous la bannière BFM
TV et de préciser les choses au dessus
donc
pour pour bien remettre dans le contexte
et redire ce qui avait été dit quand ça
arrive bien souvent que nos images
soient découpées par exemple et
on sait dire à des intervenants un bout
de ce qu'il disait mais sans les
éléments de contexte on réembête ce qui
ce qui a été
instrumentalisé pour le remettre dans le
contexte et préciser les choses quand
c'est suffisamment viral pour que ça ne
nécessite
je vous remercie il y avait une question
de La Valette
merci monsieur le Président
du coup sur sur la presse sur quel est
votre état d'esprit maintenant
sur voilà quelle est la réflexion déjà
est-ce qu'il y a une réflexion qui est
menée sur sa voix dans cette guerre de
l'information notamment typiquement avec
la guerre en Ukraine est-ce que voilà
vous voyez les choses de façon un peu
différente maintenant que cette affaire
est arrivée est-ce qu'il y a des process
par exemple qui vont être mis en place
est-ce que vous voilà craint échaudé
craint l'eau chaude chat voilà voilà
savoir maintenant est-ce que ça a changé
un peu votre état d'esprit en fait
ça n'a pas changé notre état d'esprit
parce que la vigilance en pense l'avoir
toujours eu donc on a rappelé chacun à
sa vigilance et on l'est comme d'autant
plus mais non on n'a pas comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
pas par principe après avoir vérifié
notre façon de fonctionner on n'a pas
jugé utile de devoir renforcer des
choses qui nous semblent solides et
robuste après on a rappelé à chacun à sa
vigilance
et je vous remercie madame clapot
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur chers collègues Monsieur le
Directeur général je vous prie de
m'excuser d'avance si je repose une
question qui a déjà été posée parce que
j'ai pas pu assister à la totalité en
vous écoutant je vous disais que vous
comme tout un chacun vous êtes soumis à
des injonctions contradictoires vous
êtes sur un média qui doit remplir
remplir 24 heures sur 24 une antenne des
réseaux sociaux être le premier vous
avez des objectifs d'audience aussi
parce que vous avez un modèle économique
qui est basé sur la publicité et vous
avez aussi comme injonction le rapport à
vos invités que vous avez expliqué et
puis le fait d'éviter un incident on
dirait un accident industriel donc pour
moi qui est une carrière dans
l'industrie je suis sensible à ce que
vous avez dit sur les processus sur les
chartes etc et si on file la métaphore
industrielle jusqu'au bout est-ce que
vous avez une mesure de la qualité de ce
qu'on évalue ici c'est à dire la qualité
de non occurrence de d'ingérence est-ce
que vous avez aussi un retour
d'expérience et puis quel est le plan
d'action pour filer à nouveau cette
métaphore industrielle que vous mettez
en place au vu de ces mesures je vous
remercie
pour répondre au début de votre
intervention non moi je suis pas soumis
à des injonctions contradictoires je
suis soumis à essayer de produire tous
les jours de la bonne information et je
n'ai jamais l'impression en tout cas
d'avoir à remplir j'ai plutôt notre
travail journalistique c'est plutôt de
hiérarchiser les choses et plutôt
d'éviter de mettre à l'antenne des
choses qui nous sommes pas intéressantes
mais on ne manque pas de matière donc on
ne se retrouve pas jamais depuis que je
suis là à se dire qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire c'est plus sous-entendu on n'a pas
assez pour faire et donc non c'est après
on peut contester nos choix tout ça et
libre mais
ma seule
pression c'est d'essayer de produire une
information vérifiée qui a du sens et
qui est conforme à notre ligne
éditoriale sans injonction il s'avère
que ça fonctionne et et tant mieux et
que ça produit du chiffre d'affaires qui
nous permet de travailler et plus on a
des
plus mieux ça fonctionne plus on a des
moyens et plus on peut lutter justement
parce que on a des équipes
robustes à
des éventuelles ingères ingérence mais
donc moi je n'ai pas l'impression en
tout cas de vivre au milieu d'injonction
contradictoire bien au contraire après
les seuls injonctions c'est qu'est-ce
qui nous semble-t-il doit être
l'information du jour et la façon dont
on doit on doit la traiter ça c'est pour
le premier aspect ensuite j'ai répondu
précédemment à
l'autre aspect
notre process de validation des choses
notre façon de checker contre checker
l'information notre cellule notamment
vidéo qu'on active quand quand c'est
nécessaire pour vérifier déjà tout ça ne
semble-t-il est suffisamment robuste
pour faire face à un danger réel mais
qu'on tient à distance correctement sauf
encore une fois quand on décide
volontairement de contourner les choses
comme dans toute entreprise puisque vous
n'êtes dans l'industrie si vous voulez
contourner une règle vous arrivez
toujours à le faire le problème ça
serait de ne pas en être attrapé en
l'occurrence c'est pas ce qui s'est
produit
je vous remercie même la photo vous avez
une dernière question ou plusieurs
oui
une dernière question un peu général je
le conçois aisément mais je voulais
tirer parti de votre présence parmi nous
vous êtes ça a été dit un grand
professionnel au parcours professionnel
déjà long et riche Huard à la
multiplicité des défis auxquels on va
faire froid face les journalistes les
chaînes d'information les médias de
manière générale pour rester indépendant
pour rester libre pour rester fiable
pour continuer à avoir la confiance
de nos compatriotes et ça vaut partout
dans partout dans dans le monde les
évolutions technologiques la révolution
numérique le fait que tout dans chacun
c'est ma produire de l'information
et se croit peut-être à travers les
réseaux sociaux à un moment ou un autre
pendant un quart d'heure non pas
forcément en pleine lumière mais en tout
cas lui-même journaliste de sa propre
vie est-ce que vous pensez que le
I
qui est elle et surmontable qu'elle
regarde portez-vous sur l'immensité de
de ce défi voir de ses menaces qui
pèsent sur le vrai travail de
journaliste professionnel
je vais être aussi un peu général mais
ce que vous dites pour le coup une
préoccupation quotidienne de l'ensemble
des choses oui aujourd'hui tout le monde
se croit journaliste mais ce qui n'ont
pas que journaliste soit une vertu
particulière il se trouve que c'est un
métier qui a c'est pas que il y a aucun
élément de supériorité ou je ne je parle
je veux pas dénigrer qui que ce soit
mais tout le monde parle ayant accès à
des réseaux sociaux pense faire du
journalisme mais c'est pas ça le
journalisme donc mais en revanche c'est
énormément de sources d'éléments de de
d'informations potentielles et donc oui
on peut être il y a une espèce de
confusion aujourd'hui de ce que de ce
que de ce que peut être un média en fait
un compte Twitter c'est pas un média
donc ça nous oblige d'autant plus à
faire notre métier de journaliste et je
réponds ça ça rejoint un peu ce que les
éléments c'est pour ça il faut des
moyens et donc là c'est plus global dans
le cadre
mais
une rédaction nombreuse solide ça permet
ça et ça permet justement de marquer la
différence et d'essayer d'affirmer ce
qu'on est et qu'il y ait et alors tout
ça est compliqué puisque la défiance à
l'égard des journées ça allaitante
peut-être qu'on a une part de
responsabilité c'est une réflexion enfin
en tout cas on sait exonère de rien mais
en tout cas oui le défi il est important
et les moyens sont importants et dans un
moment où c'est compliqué pour certains
médias où il y a une précarisation
du métier etc oui j'ai la chance de
travailler pour un groupe qui nous donne
des moyens jusqu'à là aussi parce que
c'est une chaîne qui fonctionne mais
quand aujourd'hui par exemple
nous pouvons nous appuyer sur les
antennes locales de BFM de BFM en région
et que depuis quatre ans que 10 chaînes
ont été lancées 200 journalistes ont été
engagés tout ça ça permet justement de
répondre à la problématique qui qui que
vous décrivez
merci beaucoup moi j'aurai aussi une
dernière question généraliste
en tant que si professionnel de des
médias journalistes avec la carrière que
vous avez et aussi le rôle particulier
que vous avez comme première chaîne
d'information on continue est-ce que
quel est votre sentiment vous sur le
risque ou la réalité de l'ingérance
étrangère en France on va se concentrer
sur politique pour pas être large pas
déborder sur l'économie mais aussi en
comparaison avec la connaissance que
vous avez de ce qui s'est passé aux
États-Unis de ce qui peut se passer avec
d'autres d'autres polémiques dans
d'autres démocraties est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment une fois de plus en
professionnel mais en tant que citoyen
mais en tant que professionnel que c'est
un vrai risque qui existe en France ou
est-ce que le risque est maîtrisé c'est
à dire qu'il y a des tentatives on peut
avoir été victime mais grosso modo c'est
une affaire dont 12 off sur plusieurs
mois sur plusieurs années même bon c'est
pas non un phénomène endémique
et d'imaginable aussi comme connaisseur
du paysage politique français ce que
vous avez l'impression que le paysage
politique français est soumis à une
forme d'ingérence ou ou vous avez
l'impression que par rapport à d'autres
démocraties ça se passe c'est pas
spécialement un sujet non pas que ça
n'existe pas mais en tout cas qu'on
n'est pas dans la situation que vous
journaliste peuvent étudier ou analyser
et partager avec les Français dans
d'autres démocraties ou est-ce que vous
avez passé d'éléments pour pour le
conclure quoi que ce soit
d'abord je suis pas un spécialiste de la
gérance mais même si ça m'intéresse
évidemment et je serai intéressé par
lire les conclusions de votre commission
évidemment mais je pense que c'est un
risque je pense que c'est un risque
maîtrisé et je pense encore une fois
sans certitude mais que la France
en est n'est pas
exonéré de service mais n'est pas une
cible majeure
je vous remercie ben écoutez chers
collègues je vous remercie pour d'avoir
assisté à cette audition pour votre
question et votre travail Monsieur le
Directeur Général que vous remercie du
temps que vous avez consacré à notre
commission de la précision
l'exhaustivité des réponses que vous
aviez apportées
de votre patience aussi par rapport à
certaines de mes remarques mais c'était
pour la bonne tenue de de cette
commission aucune incidence personnelle
je remercie aussi les services de
l'Assemblée pour cette matinée la séance
est suspendue et nous nous retrouvons à
15h pour notre prochaine audition je
vous remercie la séance est suspendue